this isn't about money from our
perspective at all this is about making
sure no one else dies the way Rob died
got it no other parent should go through
what we went through it's known as gonna
continue the team is still together and
they're gonna finish the film it has
been eight weeks since the tragic
passing of Sharkwater filmmaker Rob
Stewart off the coast of Florida and for
his parents Brian and Sandy the journey
to find the truth behind his death
continues to haunt their sleepless
nights it's tragic to lose a child but
it's it's even worse when you you know
you see what's gone wrong and you know
it didn't have to happen it just makes
it terrible this week the family filed a
wrongful death lawsuit against horizon
dive adventures of Key Largo Florida add
helium and it's operators dive
instructor Peter so teased and wife
Claudia for alleged negligence so are
you able to tell us where you feel the
neglect because I'm trying to understand
because we've heard reports of what has
happened fundamentally that they're
there two or three major things number
one the dive safety diver that was
diving with Rob was also his instructor
instructor got out out of the water
first which is a cardinal sin can I ask
a question right there cuz this is but
you know in doing all the reading and
trying to understand was the diver
instructor was he conscious when he got
to the boat was he pulled out of the
water unconscious if he got up in the
boat and he theoretic and yeah collapsed
on the boat and they rushed to him and
gave attention in Rob came up gave the
okay sign and then disappeared and so
obviously the same thing that happened
to instructor probably happened to Rob
and his other careless reckless acts too
they were using Chinese tanks that
weren't even made for the bed for the
oxygen and the test results are still
and I'm being looked into on that right
now but they were falsely stamped with
safety regulation stamps I had that dive
instructor his legal team been in
contact with you have you know
no and this instructor left the country
the next day and the coast guards met
him at the airport and confiscated its
equipment and he left Fork yourself even
worse when Brian and Sandy Stewart dug
deeper they found out that so T's has a
criminal record in Florida they also
discovered that sorties had been accused
by a former business partner of
illegally selling equipment to a
militant in Libya those allegations have
not been proven in court this man is not
a nice man he's just not to be smug
because if that man
by doing this lawsuit doesn't make it
harder for you as parents we get to
relive it on a pretty consistent basis
and that's that's tough because we don't
get a break he loved the underwater
world he wanted more people to
experience the beauty of the underwater
world and the diving is safe and there
was just so many careless careless
things that happened on that trip had
the instructors been doing their job
that boat captain doing his job Robley
be here today and that's the that's the
hardest part of it all is thing that he
didn't have to die
today we reached out to Peter so T's for
comment regarding the lawsuit and were
contacted by a lawyer named David
Concannon who has not yet been retained
but is acting as a spokesperson now he
posted a lengthy Facebook statement
explaining there are two sides to every
story and expressing that the so T's
family has fully cooperated with the
United States Coast Guard saying
allegations in a lawsuit are not always
truthful or accurate and the litigation
process tends to reveal facts that are
not always represented when a complaint
is filed Concannon also notes that so t
s-- has not filed a defense yet and as
of yesterday has not been served with
the lawsuit and of course we will update
you on Brian and Sandy Stuart's lawsuit
in the days and weeks ahead